foreign
[Music]
now also I'm not going to lose games
deliberately so I'm gonna like rise
quickly through the ranks
so I'm going to reach like a thousand
really quickly and that's going to be
part of the plan so I won't play too
many games against total beginners
so that I don't get too bogged down
um hopefully that's a fair compromise
and pretty soon I'm going to be at a
decent level where I can start talking
about openings more theoretically okay
Shivam Chauhan too all right
so
to remind people I'm playing okay
I'm playing my official opening
recommendations in the speed run and
when we get a little bit higher rated
we're actually going to face like main
lines and that's when I'll try to start
talk about Theory and I'll use every
game to advance your theoretical
knowledge and your conceptual knowledge
now these first couple games
we're obviously going to encounter these
Sidelines and these like frivolous moves
but they're not totally frivolous
they're like serious moves at a beginner
level
and there are moves that scare a lot of
people away so the important thing to do
is not to just laugh and say oh this
move's terrible Hikaru Nakamura played
Queen H5 actually in classical games
it's it's it's it's a real move and you
you actually need to know how to punish
it coincidentally I've looked at it so I
know what the best move here is
so the best move you you might think is
like D6 or or E6 to defend the C5 Pawn
but
Queen a tribe doesn't actually protect
the E4 Pawn so the best move here is
just to develop as if nothing is
happening
and of course the queen on H5 is very
vulnerable to an attack so putting all
of that together the best move here is
Knight F6
yeah this is what I think Vol Keaton
played against Hikaru and Carl played
Queen H5
now famously Hikaru played Queen H5
against E5 and it's not such a bad move
against C5 he also has played it in a
classical chess he had a phase where he
was doing this okay Queen C5 obviously
we played 94. and we've traded the
e-pawn for the C Pawn but also why it
has not developed any pieces other than
his Queen
and now our strategy is just going to be
to develop quickly and occupy our center
with bonds like the literal most basic
stuff that we do in any position
so I'm already looking at the move D5
Knight C6 B5 like it depends on where
white puts his Queen
like if the queen drops back to E3 for
example
we would play D5 the queen was back to
H5
um
okay interesting move
not particularly bad and you might be
very tempted to play G6 here let's chase
the queen away and let's prepare to feed
and Kettle the bishop
G6 is not a bad move so g6y can swing
the queen over to E5
ostensibly forking the Knight on the
road but the Knight can drop back to F6
and cover that diagonal so that's
actually a totally legitimate way to
play in fact we might play G6
we can also just continue our
development we play Knight C6
and you might say but what if white
chases away the Knight with D3 Bulls so
be it Knight's just going to drop back
to F6 and attack the queen again
so let's actually play it in the
simplest possible we're just gonna go
Knight C6
and if yeah okay Bishop C4 obviously
threatening mate
so we want to be careful okay don't go
D6 that doesn't defend the F7 Pawn
don't go D5 because there's two
attackers on D5 and only one Defender
well I can take that
so what's the best way to defend against
mate here
there's two two good moves here I would
say one one is more consistent with our
strategy
yeah E6 is good
because E6 also prepares to build up a
very nice Pawn center with D5 like this
this structure f7065 is very solid even
though I just mentioned that we would
love to play D5 and E5
that's not the only valid way to control
the center
e65 is also perfectly Rock Solid and
sufficient
okay
let's see
what
um our opponent brings to the table here
if I were playing white I would probably
play with like Knight C3
or or Z3
yeah there's a clear drawback of the
movie E6
which is that it blocks in the light
squared Bishop like once we play D5 the
bishop is going to be staring at upon
again I have no answer to that
point because it's it's a real Point
yeah the bishop might be a little bit
more passive the only thing I ever say
to that always is like not every piece
needs to be
flying through Frankfurt airport
Distributing the covert vaccine like Etc
and this is a great application of a day
it's such a ubiquitous phrase because
it's so true in so many different types
of positions
so here like it's okay to put one of
your pieces on D7 it's not gonna change
the fabric of the position
yeah D5 is a great move
defends and attacks
defends on attacks and then the bishop
light a Dark Sword Bishop could come out
to C5
attacking the F2 Pawn forcing this
awkward developing movement this should
be five
this is not a pin that we are fearing at
all
this is a totally innocuous pin white
has no way to apply pressure on the
Knight
and as I've mentioned before an easy way
to determine whether a pin is dangerous
well there's sort of a two-step process
you can say one is the pinned piece
protected by a pot if the answer is yes
chances are the pin is already much less
dangerous
then second question is the PIN likely
to be temporary the answer is also yes
because once we Castle kingside it gets
rid of the pin naturally
which means we don't really need to play
Bishop D7 we don't really need to play
A6 here we can just continue developing
according to our plan we can play Bishop
C5 attack F2
then we can castle kingside and that
frees up the Knight the Knight can jump
into D4 that's a fork against the queen
and Bishop
kind of re repurposing the PIN to our
favor
and collaborating for the subs
appreciate it
is Queen V6 ever an idea yeah I mean
obviously Queen B6 is
generally a good move in a lot of
different types of positions especially
here just attack the bishop
put pressure on Ft our opponent is is
finding the moves
but castling is more flexible right now
we're keeping our options open we're
unpinning the Knight
and remember that Queen B6 threatens the
bishop but the F2 Pawn is rather well
defended by white so you
this is not the only thing we should
attack okay D3
okay so that's probably that's a mistake
that's a blunder's material
um why is the blood of material well now
we have a move that I've already
mentioned it's a very strong move
obviously this queen on F3 is incredibly
vulnerable so you should always be
thinking about ways that you can attack
it
now there's two concrete ways that we
can attack the queen
we can play Knight to E5
okay but then the queen just drops back
that doesn't create a second threat
Knight D4 is much better because it also
threatens the bishop
now you might say okay I get it we play
Knight D4 we attack the Queen the queen
drops back
sorry Knight T4 the queen drops back we
take his Bishop but then he takes our
Knight like what what do we gain from
that trade well it's not that simple
let's let's start by playing Knight T4
and then after the queen drops back to
D1 I'm assuming otherwise the C2 Pawn
hangs with a fork
we have a strong move in that position
yeah we also create a third thread which
I forgot to mention initially Knight
takes C2 obviously
Queen A5 was also quite decent
I'll show after the game why I like it a
little bit less but it's also actually
achieves a very similar thing to Knight
D4 so
maybe even it is more accurate I don't
know
Queen A5 was a totally legitimate
alternative
and it worked much the same night okay
so yeah so that's the problem with these
games is that like if at some point like
at some point just just these players
they actually find some pretty good
moves
like you can see here white was playing
pretty good chess like Bishop C4 Queen
back to F3
Bishop B5
Knight H3 was found only move defending
the pawn but then like at some point
there's just a collapse
and and they just get overwhelmed and I
think this happens when people get
overwhelmed with threats like they see
three or four threats and and they're
just mine turns into mush
okay that's an underwhelming game
for sure but still
that's just gonna be the first couple of
games we look we're already 700 so you
won't have to wait long for us to cross
a thousand and then we'll get more
serious games
um but the game was won a little bit
earlier than that
yeah so Queen H5 Knight F6
Queen takes C5 Knight takes C4 I forgot
how the Hikaru game went I think Hikaru
took on C5 apparently Richard report
also played this of course this is total
garbage like this is like black is
already clearly better I think
and white has to be accurate in order to
avoid basically being lost
yeah I was reading a really interesting
article today on
like okay so there's this chess
historian named Edward winter
if you're watching on YouTube I highly
recommend you check out his work he has
a website called chestnuts or is it
called chess history.com
where he basically posts articles on a
bunch of different like chess topics
let me check actually
yeah it's chess history.com
good domain name
and he's like very
very biting in his reports like he
writes about really bad books and like
one of his articles is about
chess annotations like how games are
annotated
and he basically says that chess players
are known for like using cliches
constantly when they're annotating their
games
um but he he gave a couple of examples
of like really good comments and one of
them was missing an opportunity to
resign
That's Tony cower I think invented that
missing a good opportunity to resign
at some point if one side is prolonging
the game
so anyways um Queen H5 we go Knight C6
we continue our development
and Bishop C4 this threatens Checkmate
in one
this is a pattern you should be able to
quickly identify if you are a even if
you're a beginner this is like the
classic the queen from F3 or H5 attacks
F7 so does the bishop
so we just go E6 and really the main the
only conceptual challenge of this entire
game was to convince ourselves that it's
not the end of the world that the light
squared Bishop is going to be somewhat
confined by the Pawns
thank you Ghostfreak for the sub
so that's literally it once you realize
that it's okay all of the moves become
Supernatural Bishop C5 then we Castle we
free up the Knight the Knight jumps into
D4 what would we have done if White had
dropped the queen back to D1 so there's
two options here
the easy option is to play Just Knight
takes B5 de4 then we just play de4 and
we say we're up upon we've got better
development two Bishops the knight's
crappy on H3 black is much better
okay the Queens can be traded but
that doesn't change the nature of the
position black is like borderline
winning here
the second option a little bit more
convoluted is to say well two pieces are
hanging at the same time Knight and
Bishop
I've talked about the scenario I'll
length and one of the first things you
should search for is whether there is a
way
to whether there's a way to
um to give away one of the pieces for a
certain amount of material such as a
pawn and then to take the other piece
this is a Desperado sacrifice the logic
is like you're already losing the net on
e4 you might as well give it away for
like the maximum amount of material
once you phrase it that way the move
should be really easy
yeah Knight takes F2 so you it's not a
sacrificer you're taking the bishop on
the next move and so what if the bishop
moves well the bishop can't move because
the this move also attacks the queen
so in a way this almost a check you're
forcing white to take then you take the
bishop and you've removed the F2 Pawn
from the board permanently weakening
White's gang side
if okay why can Castle still but
then we can maybe play the move E5
occupying the center response the bishop
is strong the other Bishop is good as
well
this is like
yeah Queen H4 is good
it's just really really bad for white
but obviously Knight A3 Knight F3 is
just a game
yeah that's just game
and uh I'm probably gonna combine this
with another YouTube with another Speed
Run game that'll do tomorrow the
emphasis in this speedrun is on openings
I'm playing and presenting my
recommended opening repertoire with both
colors and as we climb the rating ladder
we will be spending more time talking
about Theory and talking about uh basic
opening ideas
now I I just asked that people
understand that what's a sweet spot for
you might not be a sweet spot for
somebody else so people leaving comments
and saying oh you know this is too basic
for me well put yourself in the shoes of
someone who's a beginner and who
benefits from that content and I'm
trying to like please as many people as
possible but obviously at all times it's
going to be too basic for someone and to
be too advanced for other for another
person
so just understand that I'm like I'm
doing my best
um and it's impossible to generate
content that is truly appealing to every
single level at the same time
and we're playing hand shatins let's
play E4
let's play E4
D5 so we are facing a scandi obviously
we take on D5 that's
a lot yeah we're facing Us candy which
is definitely a pretty rare guest at
like the level of it's 700 800.
um now of course if you've seen previous
Speed Run games we've faced this candy
quite a bit
and there are a couple of ways to play
it from this position you can play the
move d4
to occupy the center that's viable
possibility even the move Knight F3
nothing wrong with that but the topical
move the principled move is of course
right C3 developing with Tempo attacking
the queen this move makes by far the
most logical sense of all of White's
moves and this speaks to why the scandes
and unsound opening fundamentally
black is uh issuing all of his minor
piece development and instead moving the
queen around a bunch in the opening
Queen E6 check so what's funny is that
this this move uh it's a move that
beginners often like to make because
beginners like to give checks
and obviously it's a bad move but it's
been played like recently it has been
played by some by some GMS and black
does have a way to try to make this move
work at like a high level but obviously
at this level
most people don't play this move because
they have in mind like a deep
preparation or something like that so
how should we block the check well you
could make a case for an ige2 but the
straightforward move of course is Bishop
E2
because you could argue that Knight G2
blocks the development of the F1 Bishop
now in situations where you've blocked
the development of the bishop always
remember that you can see and keto the
bishop you can play Knight G2 and then
you can play G3 Bishop G2 so all of the
pieces are going to be happy but in this
particular instance we're going to play
a temple we're just going to play Bishop
B2
and then we're going to play Knight F3
and we're going to play D4 at some point
to occupy the center
when should you play D4 yeah you can
play D4 as soon as you complete your
minor piece development
so
the move as far as I remember
that that like the high level people
play is Queen G6
yeah Queen G6 is like the
you know the
move you're supposed to play our
opponent plays Bishop D7 okay so we're
going to continue our development with
Knight F3
and our next couple of moves are going
to be D4 Castle's King side and at some
point when we complete our development
we can start targeting Black's
incredibly vulnerable Queen on E6 which
is like standing in the middle of
everything and not allowing black uh to
properly develop
his or her pieces thank you babes think
Daddy for the sub
so it should sort of make sense to you
as you're watching this why Black's play
is incredibly dubious like moving the
queen this many times giving your
opponent a huge lead in development and
central control is going to cost black
very dearly and it's going to cost black
quickly
so my guess is that with the with his
last move Bishop D7 our opponent maybe
wants to go Knight C6 and then Castle's
Queen side
but we're not even going to allow black
the possibility to do that because in
response to Knight C6 we're just going
to push D4 straight away because that is
going to threaten a fork D4 to D5 and
forking the queen in the ninth so this
is okay H6
so our opponent continues to sort of
move random pieces allowing us to
increase our lead and development let's
Castle kingside
we also could have started with D4 it
really does not matter
in many instances like D4 Castle's King
side we can make any developing move
that we want and all of it is going to
be good this is honestly a terrible
terrible position for black
I would go so far as to say that
I would go so far as to say that black
is borderline losing here just because
our lead in development is so
overwhelming okay so Knight C6 has been
played as you can see these two pieces
are on forkable squares how do I know
that I know that because if a pawn
appears on D5 it'll be forking the queen
of the night so what's our move what if
it was obviously D4 which is what we
wanted to play anyway but now this move
is especially potent because we're
threatening to Fork the queen of the
negative five
does that make sense so T5 is a huge
threat and it's actually not such an
easy thread to deal with because the
black queen this is the danger of
putting your queen in front of all of
the pieces the queen has simply no good
squares if black shifts the queen over
to D6 which may seem like the best way
to defend against the fork who can tell
me why Queen D6 loses on this spot
why does the move Queen E6 loose
yeah Knight D5 is just game over very
good knight B5 attacks the queen forces
it away and then we win C7 with a fork
Against The Rook in the king
now you could say well okay but the
queen can go let's say the G6 but if the
queen goes to G6 we can continue pushing
our d-pawn dislodging the Knight away
from C6 and black is just we're just
gonna start rocking the rap storming the
barricades after 95.
and we're just pouncing on black given
the fact that his entire King side is
totally undeveloped
so this game is already like a lesson in
the importance of healthy development in
the opening
SO waiting on our opponent to make a
move
Black's position okay people and this is
like what I've been talking about a lot
which is that you know at this beginner
level like when beginners are faced with
like serious problems generally you know
they just like collapse completely which
is totally like okay and I'm not saying
this to embarrass anybody
uh but this is a good example of that
obviously 1964 just gives up a piece
it can take either way Knight takes D4
is I think what most people play I
really like them of Queen takes D4
because it gets the queen out into the
center and prepares stuff like Knight D5
so I think that the fastest path to
Victory if we want to win this game
quickly is is probably actually Queen 60
but there's another reason I like Queen
takes D4 which is that it prevents black
from Castle and queen side because it
aims at the A7 Pawn
so in the event of Castle's clean side
we play Queen takes a sound
but I really like the placement of the
queen on D4 because it is essentially
unassailable black has no pieces with
which to attack the queen
C5 okay Kathy there we go see it works
like a charm we can take say some of the
game is over
now we're threatening Checkmate in one
notice that our Bishop is guarding the
A6 Square
C6 okay now let's be precise right A lot
of people in these types of situations
they tend to start playing quickly we
have many ways that we can win but if we
want to deliver Checkmate as quickly as
possible
what should we start with
you'll notice that Queen A8 is not
Checkmate because of King C7 so one way
to win
one way to win would be to give the
check on A8 and then give the check on
F4 Force the king out to B6 and then
capture The Rook on d8 that's totally
winning but even faster is to play
Bishop F4 first to cover the C7 square
and thread checkmates on A8 and on B8
and Black's King is now totally done I
think black's best move is actually to
play Queen D6 and give up an entire
Queen
easy game but if you're like 700 or 800
and you're watching this video
you know you should realize that you can
you can go a long way just by playing
like natural moves in the opening like
all we did was develop our pieces that's
literally all we did
literally all we did
uh and and it results in like a 10 move
victory
so already D5 is a very bad move at a
beginner level like I never recommend
the scandi to players period but
especially not to players under like 17
1800 give or take
um and the reason is this is something
I've spoken to a lot in previous speed
runs is that when you're a beginner you
wanna
you basically you want to play openings
that allow you
to put into practice like basic opening
principles right because you're a
beginner you've just learned basic
principles and then if you play an
opening like the scandi all you're doing
is you're violating those principles so
you're creating kind of like cognitive
dissonance in your mind which is why
like I very strongly recommend beginners
to play sound healthy openings like E4
E5 or even the Sicilian my official
recommendation the speedrun is the
accelerated Dragon which we haven't had
a chance to play yet
so after thank you PVP for the 49 months
so after we trade Knight C3 of course
Queen E6 check is the wrong move
uh the main line is Queen A5
although there have been a couple of
Sidelines that have gotten popular in
recent years Queen D6 is a super topical
line and even Queen back to d8 has been
recommended by some authors I think John
Bartholomew recommends Queen d8 an
adjustable course not an easy move to
prove an advantage against actually
so Queen E6 check just allows white to
continue his development
and here black makes the serious mistake
with Bishop D7 the only way to try to
make this line work is actually to move
the queen again Queen G6
attacking the pawn on G2 and the point
is to put the queen on a relatively
invulnerable Square
so how should white defend G2 should we
play the Moto G3
or does white have a better way to
defend the G2 Pawn
it's an inaccuracy it's Queen E6 is
definitely not a blunder blunder is
something like hangs a piece yeah Bishop
F3
okay so all of you guys are on this idea
you put the bishop on a good Square
you definitely don't want to avoid you
definitely want to avoid a bit like G3
which creates unnecessary weaknesses on
the king side
so the move is definitely Bishop F3
Knight F6
and for example Knight G2
and then the Knight can go to F4 the
pawn goes to D4 and obviously white is
is is quite a bit better here but still
this is the only way to try to make this
work after Bishop D7 Knight F3 already
black is in serious trouble H6 castles
okay Knight C6 and after D4
as I said black is borderline Lost Queen
D6 loses to Knight B5 as we discussed I
think the only way to prolong the game
for black was probably something like
Queen G6
but here we can still play D5
we can also play a simple developing
move like Bishop F4 targeting the C7
plot but we're totally spoiled for
Tracer but the way I would play it is D5
and if black plays the Knight before I
think we have a pretty instructive
sequence
so here we can play the move Knight F3
to E5 totally natural move hitting the
queen hitting the bishop but it may seem
like a blunder due to Queen takes C2 and
here if you look carefully you will see
that white has a very very powerful
response who can find it
what should I do so we know that we want
to avoid a queen Trend because in the
event of a queen trade your ability to
conduct the initiative and just the
overall effect of your development
Advantage greatly diminishes
so okay but think about how I can avoid
the queen trade yeah very good you can
just move the queen out of the way to D4
Queen D4 is a super powerful move
because not only does it avoid a queen
trade it also attacks the Knight on
before it comes with Tempo and remember
you also have this threat of taking the
bishop on D7 driving black skiing out of
the shell after Queen D4 white is
already totally winning totally winning
and in addition to all of that you can
also play them with Bishop D3 trapping
the queen on C2 and winning the queen
if C5 then you have on Passat so
this is just game over straight away
yeah there is a way to trap the Blackfin
black cannot keep the Knight on before
if black plays E6 then the simplest is
just to play Knight takes D7 and d e
check
and drives the king out of its shell
this is going to be Checkmate in a
couple of moves
so all very very simple stuff but
obviously after Knight D4 Queen before
the game ends immediately we're just up
a piece and we're driving our Knight
into D5 The Bishop's coming out to C4
this is all very very straightforward
Queen takes a seven threads Checkmate
and then Bishop F4 deprives the king of
its only Escape square and here black
resigned so so far you know the speedrun
games might seem overwhelming but again
we're laying the groundwork we're
playing basic moves and these basic
moves are allowing us to win all of our
games quickly when we hit the level of
like a thousand you're gonna find that
the game start getting a little bit
juicier but I think it's important for
us to lay this groundwork so that we can
benefit more from the more complex
discussions that we're going to have at
when we climb
so I hope you guys enjoyed I have to get
going
all right thank you all and see you
later
[Music]